you
we make live wallpapers and Android is
the only platform that supports that and
I was incredibly easy to get up and
running with it the best part about ICS
is probably you know from an end user
standpoint just the interface is just
amazingly improved and it's cohesive
across the tablets the Android
developers keep adding great new api's
and features that are just you know make
it a dream to the bell for that we can
be opening up an SDK which means Android
app developers can create apps and
upload them somewhat live so we have two
apps coming up in the future once a poll
our app which hooks up by bluetooth to
Polo harmless they can see your heart
rate as you're skiing and snowboarding
another app we've got coming up is the
contour out so contours a point of view
video camera at the moment you don't
know where it's pointing and it's on
your helmet you don't have this covered
in snow when our HUD will turn into
viewfinder so you can see what filming
as you're filming it we develop for
android because it allows us to little
red quickly and release when we want to
a lot when somebody else I think anyone
has a very bright future future the best
part about ice cream sandwiches general
beam in our opinion so you can really
put together two devices and people can
play together instance
you